on Sunday President Trump had had enough
he pointedly tweeted I hereby demand and
will do so officially tomorrow that the
Department of Justice look into whether
or not the FBI
DOJ infiltrated or surveilled the Trump
campaign for political purposes and if
any such demands or requests were made
by people within the Obama
administration well Trump has good
spidey sense this is nothing new in a
way on March 4th
2017 more than a year ago President
Trump contended that his phones were
tapped just prior to the election and of
course the get Trump media and the deep
state all dismissed it it was all a
bunch of nonsense well of course we now
know that the Justice Department sought
and secured permission to surveil Trump
advisor Carter Page whom you'll hear
from in just a moment the problem was
that 2016 page FISA warrant was obtained
in part using fraudulent information
from that infamous steel dossier paid
for by the Clinton campaign now again
reset your brain for a moment think
about that in the middle of a
presidential election when a man who's
running for president is vowing to drain
the swamp there could have been a plot
hatched at the senior levels of our
government to entrap secondary figures
in the Trump campaign to ultimately get
to Donald Trump himself then those
figures were targeted and surveilled
again even possibly Trump himself well
of course
Democrats laughed laughed all this off
as spurious that's claimed by the
president's suggestion by Giuliani that
there's a political spy embedded in the
Trump campaign is nonsense and you hear
it in the same terms that Trump often
speaks which is people are saying or I'm
hearing or we're being told that's
another way of saying this is patently
untrue true but we would like to spread
it anyway and it's singly destructive of
our institutions but then that's the
point
no
congressman Schiff the point is day by
day we learn more information that seems
to indicate that the government may have
used its prosecutorial and investigative
powers for a political end to do what
well to stop candidate Trump and when
that failed to derail his presidency
this is the deep state inaction I think
it's really unwise to dismiss out of
hand the notion that the FBI could have
found it within itself to spy on the
Trump campaign if they never would have
done that well as the Federalist David
Hassan Yee reminds us John Brennan spied
on the legislative branch and lied about
it to the American people James clapper
spied on the American people through a
domestic surveillance program and lied
to it to cut about it to Congress and
although the Obama administration never
tweeted any nasty attacks on journalists
it did spy on and prosecute them it's
completely plausible then that those in
the upper echelon of law enforcement saw
Trump as a threat then used wobbly
evidence as the pretext to investigate
his campaign close quote the great piece
by the way for more than a year now the
president and the House Intel committee
led by Devin Nunez has sought the
initial unredacted documents that
sparked this collusion probe well today
the FBI director and the deputy AG have
agreed to give congressional members
access to highly classified documents
about the Russia probe now they want to
see the information concerning the FBI
informant who reportedly cozied up to at
least three Trump associates now whether
you call this an gaya spy or an
informant or just a mole who cares
it's just semantics according to reports
the FBI sent this informant out to make
contact with Carter page George
papadopolis and Sam Clovis now this
informant reportedly had a sit-down with
Carter page in early July of 2016 well
that's interesting
because that undermines former FBI
director Jim Comey's contention that the
FBI didn't begin its investigation until
late July huh
incidentally between 2012 and all the
way up to 2018 now according to public
records this same informant received
more than a million dollars the kind of
general foreign policy research and he
conducted this all through the
Department of Defense another
interesting point it's all very fishy
come on it many questions remain about
this and there are unanswered today
following that White House meeting the
president said he has been able to get
the Justice Department to authorize
another Inspector General probe into
these spy allegations well the problem
with referring this investigation to the
inspector general as good of a guy as he
is he has no prosecutorial or official
subpoena powers so even if he does find
rank abuse by Obama officials or perhaps
who knows even Obama himself if he knew
about it the Inspector General will only
be able to refer that information to the
Justice Department
well good does that end up doing well
the president in all of us do have a
right to know the names of any and all
Americans who were surveilled as part of
this anti-trump hit squad over at the
DOJ and when we finally get to the
bottom of all this we should have the
names of any officials current or former
who were part of what I believe was an
obscene Beus of power they should be
held accountable all of them to the
fullest extent of the law and of course
the $64,000 question is who else in the
Obama administration other than Jim call
me the other people have already been
identified signed off on this approved
of this how much did Attorney General
Loretta Lynch know about crossfire
hurricane and yeah while there is
historical distance between the White
House
and the DOJ on ongoing cases kind of
independence you think about it it kind
of is unfathomable that Jim Comey and
company would conduct an operation like
this one without at least informing the
President of the United States of course
then Barack Obama as long as these
questions hang out there I really
believe that Americans more and more of
them are going to think that our
government tried and maybe is still
trying to pull off a political coup
against the anti-establishment figure
Donald Trump and that's the angle